Gabrielle Proulx, reportages.
(musique dramatique)
- La Terre compte près
de 8 milliards d'êtres humains.
Ce qui veut dire qu'en 200 ans,
la population mondiale a été
multipliée par huit.
Avec le réchauffement
climatique, quelle pression
cela met sur la planète?
DIENE KEITA, dir. exécutive
adjointe en charge, UNFPA
- 8 milliards de population,
ce ne sera jamais trop sur
la Terre. Il s'agit de trouver
les bonnes opportunités
pour les populations, où
qu'elles soient, et
d'éviter les inégalités
et de leur permettre de
bénéficier de leurs droits.
- Pour Samuel Lesage et
sa conjointe Anne-Marie
Dubreuil, qui ont 31 ans,
il est hors de question
d'avoir un enfant.
SAMUEL LESAGE
- Si j'avais un enfant,
j'aurais extrêmement de gêne
en le regardant dans les yeux,
en lui disant :
ça va bien tout ça?
En sachant que le monde
court vers la catastrophe
climatique en ce moment.
ANNE-MARIE DUBREUIL- - - - Dansl
on vit, est-ce que ça fait
du sens pour moi? Bien,
on a décidé que non.
- Il y a un an, Samuel a subi
une vasectomie.
- C'est une prise de position.
Pour moi, il y a quelque
chose... il y a un refus.
Je refuse une certaine société
qui, par son idéologie,
nous dit : "Tout va aller
bien. Maintenons le statu quo.
Les enfants, c'est la plus belle
chose qui puisse vous arriver.
Les enfants sont porteurs
de l'avenir."
J'en ai pas de foi en l'avenir.
J'en ai pas du tout.
- Le couple est conscient
qu'un enfant de moins
sur Terre, ça ne résoudra
pas la crise climatique.
Selon la Banque mondiale,
l'empreinte carbone
des Canadiens est trois fois
importante que la moyenne
mondiale.
Bref, ce n'est pas tant
le nombre d'êtres humains,
mais plutôt le mode de vie des
Canadiens et des pays développés
qui pose problème, selon
la biologiste de l'Université
McGill, Catherine Potvin.
CATHERINE POTVIN, prof. au Dép.
de biologie de l'Uni. McGill
- Un Canadien, ça utilise
environ 25 fois plus d'énergie
dans sa vie qu'un Chinois.
Les grosses autos, le climat
ne nous aide pas, puis les
distances ne nous aident pas.
Mais, en dehors du climat et
des distances, c'est notre modes
maisons, de grosses voitures.
On vit de plus en plus
en banlieue. Tout le monde veut
faire des voyages à l'extérieur.
- Même si la population
mondiale continue de
s'accroître et pourrait
atteindre les 10 milliards
d'humains en 2050, le rythme
RiRiRiRiRiRien à voir avec
le baby-boom des années 60.
Et l'élément positif dans
tout ça, selon cet économiste,
les populations augmentent
surtout dans les pays qui
produisent moins de gaz
à effet de serre.
CHARLES SÉGUIN, prof. au Dép.deM
- Évidemment, ça va dépendre
de comment ces pays-là croissent
au niveau de leur économie,
puis on voudrait idéalement
qu'ils n'aient pas la même
trajectoire de croissance
que nous on a connu.
- Patrick Bonin, le responsable
de la campagne Climat-Énergie
chez Greenpeace Canada, comprend
l'éco-anxiété chez certaines
personnes qui décident
de ne pas avoir d'enfants.
aiaiaiaiaiaiait un choix
différent. Il est aujourd'hui
père de trois enfants.
PATRICK BONIN, resp. campagne-ÉA
- Faut pas penser que le passé
est garant de l'avenir.
Il y a une jeune dame,
Greta Thunberg, qui a commencé
à faire une journée de grève par
semaine et ça s'est transformé
en un mouvement où il y adededes
Greta Thunberg à travers
la planète qui ont été
mobilisés dans leur comté.
- Selon lui, les parents peuvent
aussi apprendre à leurs enfants
comment avoir l'empreinte
écologique la plus faible.
- C'est certain que
les transports, la diminution
de l'utilisation de l'auto-solo,
c'est central. On n'y arrivera
pas si on ne diminue pas aussi
notre consommation de viande,
par exemple. Aussi, si on ne
diminue pas la surconsommation
en général, pensez au plastique
à usage unique.
- Pour le militant écologiste,
chaque petit g
mais convient que l'appui
des gouvernements reste
plus que nécessaire pour
renverser la vapeur.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.